and we're getting new images tonight of
what Venezuela says is the second
American behind a failed plot to
overthrow the Venezuelan government
State Department correspondent
Richardson has the images more captive
videos emerge from the Venezuelan
government of Nicolas Maduro these
apparently of the second former US Green
Beret in the regime's custody under
arrest this man claims he's Erin berry
and when questioned he says he's part of
an incursion into Venezuela this weekend
to push Maduro from power the regime
already aired a video of a man in
custody claiming to be another former
Green Beret Luke Denman as the Maduro
regime continues exploiting the
Americans in propaganda Nicolas Maduro
claims the US government pushed this
operation Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
denies that the effort that we've seen
stories on these last few days was not
an American effort but we do believe
that Maduro must go he want to try and
restore that democracy for the
Venezuelan people members of Congress
are also asking the Trump administration
about any US knowledge of the operation
the State Department spokesperson says
quote the United States government was
not involved in recent events in
Venezuela involving mr. Goudreau there
is a major disinformation campaign
underway by the Maduro regime making it
difficult to separate facts from
propaganda the self-proclaimed architect
of a failed infiltration into Venezuela
this weekend is under investigation for
potential arms trafficking violations US
officials say they're looking into the
florida contractor and ex-green beret
jordan Gaudreau the Maduro regime says
it wants to extradite Gaudreau the State
Department says it will use all
available tools to try to free the
Americans from maderos custody though
the United States has no official
relationship with maderos government and
is instead trying to push it from power
brett richardson at the State Department
rich thanks